one of the videos i watched of you there
was a quote of john adams and it said
there are two ways to conquer
and enslave a nation
one is by the sword
and the other is by debt
okay which is part of your formula what
you guys did right it was a lot of debt
and you're forcing them to do whatever
you want them to do right okay
there's this country
that is creating a lot of momentum i
don't know if you've heard them it's
called china
and china
u.s owes to china
1 trillion
500
i think it's 1 trillion 50 billion
dollars is what we owe china okay 1.05
trillion in debt to china
so if this quote is right there are two
ways to conquer and enslave a nation
one is by the sword the others by the
debt by debt
is america enslaved to china
this is a really important question pat
um and it's the book i'm writing now
comes out in october it's called
contest new confessions of an economic
hitman edition three china's economic
hitmen
and i've been spending the last three or
four years working on this book china
owns the world now pretty much
and they do it under the guise of the
new silk road which is very appealing to
countries in africa and latin america
and the middle east and all over that
will become part of an
international trading network the united
we our economic hit men were never smart
enough to come up with that kind of a
scenario they get a great message
and yes
i think it
the united states and china are
incredibly
interwoven and china's winning this
battle if you want to call it a battle
but at the same time the united states
is also gaining a lot so
our investors have over 100 billion
dollars invested in china you know where
would microsoft be without china where
would apple be where would where would
any of these high-tech companies be
without china and its technology
a third of all the international
students in the united states today are
chinese they're here learning incredibly
from us they're learning all about us
we're not doing the same thing we're
criticizing china but we're not really
sending many people over to really try
to understand what's going on in china
they don't let you oh yeah they do no
they don't you can go and study in china
let me ask you let me ask you a question
when it comes down to
media we're open we tell the world about
our problems china doesn't tell the
world about their problems
they're very much of a
secrecy where we can't learn about them
that's that that's that's a
misconception pat i hate to say about i
taught in a business school in shanghai
an nba school it's right it's constantly
ranked as one of the top ten in the
world along with harvard and stanford
and so on
the chinese students there know
everything about what's going on in the
world
many of them studied here or in or in
europe i don't think you got what i said
i said we don't know about what china's
doing because china doesn't want the
world to know what they're doing well we
can go there and learn they don't have
open media they don't have a free press
well they don't there's no social media
in china no just they don't have free
press well you say one bad thing about
the
g
you're jack ma you disappear for five
months everyone's scared shitless their
biggest influence on their biggest
platform that's a tick tock type of a
model
she had like 50 million followers she
disappeared just because she said one
bad thing and supported the people in
yeah that that's true within china but
outside of china there's a lot of
information that's available
what is the information that you think
is not available what do you mean what
is the information that's not available
china says the unemployment is two
percent do you believe that
do you believe their unemployment is two
percent i do
you believe china
i believe that point five billion people
living there slave trade you're talking
about people working in
you know
yeah the weak you're saying their
unemployment is only two percent come on
john i mean you're counting me right now
if that's what you want me to believe i
don't know whether two percent but it's
low it's very low it's it's it's low i
mean they're putting people to work
tremendously they've brought
close to 800 million people out of
poverty in the last
30 years that's more than the whole rest
of the world combined which is true but
they they've great for them and they've
had part of that as they had hit on the
back of america 10 average annual
growth in their economy would it never
happen without nixon and us though
oh yeah that's true i don't know that of
course the world knows that well nixon
went there you mean nixon is the reason
why the trade opened up with china so
it happened on the backs of america
well that's well you can say that but
you can also say that america has
tremendously profited off china because
as i said our high-tech industries
wouldn't be here without without chinese
goods i don't know i think that's a
strategically a flawed
that's a flawed strategy u.s took which
i would agree with that they rely too
much on one country and now they're
paying a price for it yeah so
so who's so what i'm trying to say is
there's a tremendous interrelationship
between these two countries right now
i don't think we can survive without
china right now and i don't think china
can survive without us they need our
market
and the two countries have an incredible
exchange of information and knowledge
all of our high-tech companies like
apple and
have
offices have facilities in china their
high-tech companies have facilities here
there's a huge interchange in that and i
think what we need to do
instead of just always looking at china
as the bad guy and yeah china's made a
lot of mistakes they've done a lot of
horrible things yes the uyghurs and and
what's going on in the south china sea
what's going on in taiwan and hong kong
i'm not apologizing for china what i am
saying is in this world today
these countries are very interdependent
this is not like the soviet union in the
united states we were never
interdependent we did not rely on the
soviet union for technology or anything
else soviet union never offered the
world anything the world really wanted
the soviet union was powerful because it
had nuclear weapons that's it there's
eighth of china's economy by the way
right not even that's russia today the
so yeah the soviet union but you know i
knew a lot of students in latin america
who were marxists
and they would go to school in russia
but they didn't consider russia to be
marxist they consider russia to be
stalinist and they did not want want
ecuador or peru or argentina to have any
government like the soviet union they
did not want to have the economy of the
soviet union they do want the economy
that china has they want to see the kind
of growth that china has demonstrated to
the world that it can do
from 1973 until now china's had
incredible economic growth you know
what's happened in the united states
we've gone from 60 of the population
being in the middle class to 50
we have not had an increase in average
wage when you account for inflation
since 1973 why do you think that is
terrible economic approach or in our
country terrible what it's uh it's our
economic system in this country i don't
think it's economical what do you think
it is you think it's economical
you talked about your three guys that
are the richest people that have half
the money right that you talk about as
well okay how do you think they got them
how do you think they got well
you you can't generalize it i mean
there's many different okay how do they
do it just give me your idea how do you
think they got that how do you become
that wealthy in america if i knew i'd
probably be one of them but i don't know
what i'm saying you you probably know
because you're up there you tell me
i'm asking you because you i don't know
i don't know how they got there but but
what i do know but what i do note pat is
that they're not being taxed for it and
they're using and their companies are
using infrastructure they're they're
using all of them stop john that's that
argument you're going to lose
to who's not being taxed for it do you
know who's paid the most taxes
in the history of america an individual
you know who's paid the most taxes ever
in the history of america no who i said
you know what he paid this year no 11
billion and what percentage of that was
uh versus his income what was his tax
what was his number it's not about his
taxes he didn't take incomes if he takes
income he pays taxes on it's not on
capital gains yeah so that's capital
gains but the point is to make to pay
that much taxes that's more than every
single us president in the history of
america combined in their lifetime
yeah big that presidents don't make much
money
okay so the american president go take
every congressman every senator every
president every governor combine all of
their taxes in their lifetime this guy
paid more in one year and guys like you
and guys like others in in in politics
bash this guy you know how much he gave
to charity yesterday how much do you
think you have to charity yesterday
charity i don't really six billion
so what's what's the big whoopee but
what the point six billion i mean what's
it how much is it taken out of the
system no no but the point is the
government who says give us more taxes
and we do
and we give them more taxes
we see nothing
and there's zero accountability the
difference is an elon musk is publicly
scrutinized constantly because there is
a form of accountability in the free
market price free
free enterprise there is zero
accountability with the government if i
go to tsa for customer service they
treat me like [ __ ]
if i go to clear they treat me royally
clear is a free market company tsa is a
government organization they flat out
disrespect you at tsa they do not clear
so the american people are sitting there
saying johnny we'll give more money to
the government just show us what the
hell you're doing with it because you
haven't proven yourself
every time you tell us give us more
money you raise taxes raise taxes raise
taxes we don't see any results so what
do you want to do at this point so pat
tell me then why has there been no real
increase in wages
in the real average wage in this country
since 1973 why is the middle class gone
from 60 of the population to 50
why did all the the the the the 200 or
400 and how many billionaires we've got
now what is it uh
it's uh
747-42 i think something like that
billionaires made uh i can't remember
the numbers now but seventy percent more
than they had during the pandemic why
and
you want me to give you the answer yeah
i'll give you the answer i'll give you
the answer you're ready yeah okay
ever wonder why politicians
never spend any of their time
coming out with programs to educate low
and middle-income families on how to get
out of debt
ever wonder why politicians don't want
to low on middle-income families to
become wealthy and make money do you
ever wonder
maybe these guys don't want you to be an
upper class maybe they want to keep you
at low income maybe they want to keep
you at middle income why
because if they do every two to four
years when they need your vote
they're gonna get your vote when's the
last time you saw a governor a senator a
congressman emphasize education to
adults on how money works so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you